five kilometers north of their base camp
at tweet law troopers of the 100 first
airborne division begin a
search-and-destroy operation filmed on
august five and six the operation is
aimed at viet cong tax collectors
reported in the area on the perimeter of
the landing zone the units are formed up
for the sweet and the advanced begin
pushing northward toward a village in
the foothills the cavalry men are
suddenly taken under fire by enemy
snipers as they cross an overgrown rice
paddy the fire seems to be coming from a
banana Grove up ahead now it's a
watching and waiting game after a while
the sniping stops and all along the line
the troopers begin easing forward they
enter the banana Grove but find no one
still farther on they come to the edge
of a village it's deserted artillery
support has called up to hit the
surrounding hills where it is believed
the BCR hiding
during the rest of the day and the
following day as the sky troopers
continue sweeping forward through
suspected enemy villages Vietcong
suspects come down out of the hills and
surrender
flying through the air are the
lightweight howitzers of an artillery
battery of the 100 first airborne
division the guns are enroute from CLE
wah to the area around dongguan 15
kilometers to the north the M 102s are
being delivered to this forward position
so they can provide supporting fire for
friendly forces operating in the area
battery personnel quickly prepare the
air mobile 105's for the firing mission
to hit Vietcong forces hiding in the
Hills
the firing rate is stepped up as
observers report the VCR taking
casualties and stammering they further
report that as a result many viet cong
are surrendering to the waiting man of
the 100 first
a tanker in Cam Ranh Bay the army
aircraft maintenance ship Corpus Christi
Bay a converted seaplane tender performs
the functions of a floating maintenance
Depot it is equipped for a wide variety
of aircraft overhaul operation
replacement parts for on-the-spot
repairs are taken aboard the ship to
support maintenance for both rotary and
fixed-wing aircraft with few areas on
the vessel large enough to accommodate
extensive airframe repair the army
flattop concentrates on overhaul of all
types of aircraft components each man in
the floating maintenance battalion has
been trained in several aircraft
maintenance specialties at the army
aeronautical depot maintenance center in
Corpus Christi Texas the damaged or
deteriorated components are brought from
the combat zone directly to the
maintenance ship for repair this avoids
the long costly shipment back to death
owes in conus and ensures return of the
items to combat in the shortest possible
time a traffic control center channels
each repair operation to the appropriate
maintenance shop
there are 32 separate aircraft
maintenance shops aboard the Corpus
Christi bay with capability for all
types of disassembly repair and rebuild
the shops are equipped with latest tools
and machinery for literally hundreds of
detailed aircraft maintenance functions
extensive laboratory support is
available for maintenance of electronic
components specialists in avionics use
complex testing equipment in checking
out sensitive communications and
guidance systems
on deck a repaired component is loaded
for quick return to the user unit
the Army's first floating aircraft
maintenance depot offers complete
mobility and flexibility of support to
US Army aircraft operations in Vietnam
on 6 August Army Chief of Staff General
Harold k johnson accompanied by sergeant
major of the army William wooldridge
arrives at brigade headquarters 100
first airborne division after being
greeted by officers of various units
general Johnson and Brigadier General
Pearson commander of the 10 first here
the reading of a citation to Lieutenant
Colonel Henry Emerson for gallantry
under fire the army chief of staff then
presents the Silver Star with first
cluster and his congratulations
afterwards general Johnson meets the
sergeant majors of the 100 first and
supporting units then he returns to his
plane to continue his tour of Vietnam
army units of the Dominican Republic
including members of this Special Forces
battalion are receiving training
encounter gorillas and riot control
tactics at a mountain school under the
guidance of personnel of the US Army's
82nd Airborne Division to accustom the
Dominican troops to moving rapidly
across country they are taught basic
mountain climbing techniques here they
rappel down the face of a cliff after
receiving instruction in special methods
of rigging they gain experience in
actual descent the troops also learn to
deal with other obstacles which they may
encounter in pursuit of a guerrilla band
under conditions intentionally made
difficult they erect rope bridges and
try their hands plus legs and elbows at
a river crossing because many of the
soldiers cannot swim United States
instructors act as lifeguards but
there's a penalty for failure a series
of push-ups from a submerged rock
the Dominican troops learn another
method of affecting a river crossing
with their equipment this time by
preparing rafts from their ponchos with
the rafts completed the men shove off
following Dominican military tradition
these two officers cross with the troops
weaponry courses are designed to take
advantage of available material the men
receive instruction in the use of
explosives in classes and in the field
then they have the opportunity to put
their knowledge to the test to gain an
understanding of guerrilla tactics one
section of troops ambushes a convoy
operated by another section explosive
charges stop the convoy
then the attackers search convoy
personnel capture weapons and retrieve
the troops also are taught riot control
formations and movements to enable them
to deal with insurrection
United States troops provide guidance as
the Dominican forces progressed in
teamwork military discipline and esprit
de corps to give the troops a first-hand
experience with the effects of tear gas
they are required to enter a tent in
which teargas grenades have been fired
and stay long enough to give their names
some of the men and her willingly others
unwillingly
when the 7th Special Forces Group
arrived in Constanza about a year ago
they found the city without public
medical facilities at that time
detachment commander captain Nestor
Pinot investigated the situation and
learned that the only hospital had been
closed down by the government in 1963
the abandoned building had since become
the home of 17 families who had taken
refuge there after migrating to
Constanza in search of employment more
than a hundred persons most of them
children were crowded into the small
building to alleviate the situation
captain Pino called together become
stanza Citizens Council under his
leadership a drive was begun to raise
money for equipping a new hospital and
to provide new housing for the migrant
families a building site was selected
and volunteers began work on the
foundation for 17 new homes most of the
building supplies were flown in because
roads in the area were nearly impassable
loads of lumber cement and even food for
the workers were trucked to the
construction site everyone pitched in to
help on 21 july six men from the 47th
engineers moved to Constanza to join the
dominican volunteers working on the
project total costs for the
reestablishment program were estimated
at twelve thousand dollars of which the
Citizens Council managed to raise nearly
half the rest was pledged by a i.d the
Community Development Office and the
Dominican Red Cross construction moved
along rapidly and within two weeks the
homes were complete each includes a
combination living room dining room two
bedrooms a kitchen and a bathroom
everything is ready on dedication day
the eighth of august people from all
parts of the district arrived for the
ceremony they hear an address by dr
orlando cepeda of the citizens council
officially naming the project kennedy
colony finally the houses are blessed by
a local priests for the 17 families
living in the old hospital it's moving
day at last each family was given
outright ownership of their new home
provided that they lived there for five
years successful relocation of these
families was only the first phase of the
civic action program in constanta to
reestablish medical facilities as
quickly as possible the Special Forces
team set up a small dispensary in a
local government building
although staffed at first by Special
Forces personnel a local doctor soon
agreed to lend his services here he
treats a small boy with severe burns on
both feet Dental as well as medical aid
was offered and as the lines of patients
grew a local girl was trained as a
nursing assistant to date treatment has
been provided here for many thousands of
cases the success of becomes tons a
dispensary is being duplicated in the
town of La Vega 48 kilometres away here
another 7th Special Forces team has set
up to dispensaries in the past year as
in Constanza local volunteers donate
their time in exchange for medical
training this dispensary handles 150
patients a day and when the Special
Forces team leaves the work will be
carried on by the newly trained
assistants with a part-time help of
local physician in the meantime medics
work around the clock to provide free
medical attention to needy Dominican
you